WE'LL BRING YOU A LOT MORE
COVERAGE OF THIS ONE-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY HERE ON CNN.
BUT FIRST, FRESH GUNFIRE IS
BEING REPORTED IN KAZAKHSTAN'S
LARGEST CITY.
THE RUSSIAN STATE NEWS AGENCY
REPORTING THAT WITNESSES SAY
SOLDIERS FIRED AT PROTESTERS AND
VEHICLES.
THIS COMES AFTER WEDNESDAY'S
CHAOTIC PROTEST AGAINST THE
AUTOCRATIC GOVERNMENT.
POLICE SAY DOZENS OF
DEMONSTRATORS WHO THEY CALL
ATTACKERS HAVE BEEN KILLED.
THEY SAY THAT 13 OFFICERS WERE
ALSO KILLED IN THE CLASHES, ONLY
TO LISTEN TO WHAT SOUNDS LIKE
GUNFIRE RINGING OUT ON THE
STREETS.
[ SOUND OF GUNFIRE ]
RUSSIAN-LED FORCES ARE NOW
MOVING IN.
KAZAKHSTAN USED TO BE A SOVIET
REPUBLIC, AND IT MAINTAINS VERY
CLOSE TIES WITH MOSCOW.
UNTIL NOW IT'S BEEN RELATIVELY
STABLE.
NIC ROBERTSON LOOKS AT HOW A
SPIKE IN FUEL PRICES UNLEASHED A
WHOLE LOT OF ANGER.
>> Reporter: EARLIER, PROTESTERS
CLASHING WITH SECURITY FORCES
OUTSIDE ALMATY'S PRINCIPAL
GOVERNMENT BUILDING, ANGERED BY
RAPIDLY RISING FUEL PRICES.
SMOKE BILLOWING FROM STUN
GRENADES AS THE COUNTRY REELS
AMIDST THE NATION'S BIGGEST
PROTEST IN DECADES.
ONE UNCONFIRMED VIDEO CLIP
APPEARS TO SHOW A SOLDIER DOWN
BEING DRAGGED AWAY FROM THE
PROTEST BY COLLEAGUES.
THE SOLDIER'S CURRENT CONDITION
ALSO UNKNOWN.
ANOTHER UNCONFIRMED CLIP APPEARS
TO SHOW SOLDIERS WITH PROTESTERS
ON THE RUN.
ONE PERSON IN BLACK CLEARLY
BEATEN WITH BATONS BY THOSE IN
UNIFORM.
IN THE RUNNING BATTLES,
PROTESTERS OFTEN SEEMING TO HAVE
THE UPPER HAND.
THE TRUTH OF OF THE LARGER
SITUATION DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN AS
PARTS OF ALMATY IN DARKNESS,
ELECTRICITY SUPPLIES CUT, SO DO
THE INTERNET.
EARLY WEDNESDAY, OFFICIALS
SAYING MORE THAN 200 PROTESTERS
HAVE BEEN DETAINED.
95 SECURITY OFFICERS INJURED,
AND 37 OF THEIR VEHICLES
DAMAGED.
BY LATE WEDNESDAY, THE PRESIDENT
HAD TAKEN CHARGE OF NATIONAL
SECURITY AND VOWING NOT TO BE
FORCED OUT, DESCRIBING A
WORSENING SITUATION AND WITHOUT
OFFERING EVIDENCE, BLAMING
OUTSIDE FORCES.
>> Translator: THESE TERRORIST
GANGS WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY
INTERNATIONAL, THEY HAVE
UNDERGONE SERIOUS TRAINING
ABROAD.
THEIR ATTACK ON KAZAKHSTAN CAN
AND SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AN ACT
OF AGGRESSION.
>> Reporter: THE PRIME MINISTER
REPLACED THE GOVERNMENT OFFERED
ITS RESIGNATION, FUEL PRICE
HIKES RESCINDED AND THE COUNTRY
PUT UNDER A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
IN MOSCOW THE NATION'S CLOSEST
ALLY, CONCERN AND CALLS FOR
CALM.
>> RUSSIA'S FOREIGN MINISTRY
SAYING THEY HOPE FOR A PEACEFUL
SOLUTION AND A QUICK RETURN TO
NORMAL.
THE KREMLIN SPOKESMAN SAYING
IT'S IMPORTANT THERE'S NO
OUTSIDE INTERFERENCE, A HINT AT
WESTERN INTERFERENCE, SAYING
RUSSIA BELIEVES KAZAKHSTAN CAN
SOLVE THIS ALONE.
BY NIGHTFALL, CHAOS IN SEVERAL
OF KAZAKHSTAN'S PRINCIPAL
CITIES.
THE GOVERNMENT CALLING FOR HELP
FROM REGIONAL ALLIES INCLUDING
RUSSIA.
UNCLEAR IF THE GOVERNMENT'S
MOVES WILL